to find the origin of valic the most
feared demon in the controvers lore to
date we must look to the legends passed
down in one small town in romania the
tales tell of a duke in the dark ages
which puts us somewhere between 500 and
1000 ce
he built a great castle which would
later be known as the abbey of saint
carter hidden in the dungeons was a
summoning ground
carved with the serpentine symbol of a
mythical being known as valic
the people in town feared the duke
because he wrote countless texts on
witchcraft and rituals to call upon
these evil forces of hell
he would eventually use these spells to
open the gateway between our world and
the underworld
by sacrificing five people as a part of
his spell the duke would allow valic to
come through and walk amongst the living
but as valik rose through the crevices
the church who had caught wind of the
foul things happening there stormed the
castle and interrupted the liturgy
they attempted to seal the gateway using
liquid from the holy grail and while
this appeared to cause the portal to
close back up the seal would not last
forever
to learn the secrets of valid's past the
entity's true purpose and what it
represents for the story
and the character's future stick around
to the end of this video
welcome to horror history my name is
professor sisi's world and you better
pay attention this tiny little piece of
[ __ ] in today's lesson we're going over
what i consider to be the main boss of
the conjuring franchise like its
counterpart malthus from the annabelle
spin-offs valik is based on a
mythological deity from the lesser key
of solomon
a series of grimoires on demonology it's
divided into five books one of which is
called
ars gowezia a textbook guide to
conjuring demons
in annabelle ours gowetzia was replaced
with this textbook called the devil's
welcome but to learn about valic we need
to turn the clock back
even further and look into the pages of
these mysterious texts found in a tomb
just outside the abbey of saint carter
[Applause]
when the ancient books are discovered we
can see the outer cover of three of them
two of them have piercing yellow
serpentine eyes much like the eyes of
valic and anyone else the demon takes
control of this suggests that these
books
unlike the devil's welcome may
specifically be about valic
the snake eating its own tail symbol is
commonly associated with valik in the
movie
but i'll come back to that shortly in
ars goethe there are 72 demons said to
have been commanded by the israeli king
solomon
they range from kings dukes princes
marquises
knights presidents and earls valic is
considered a president of hell
in the mythology valic looks a lot
different than it does in the conjuring
movies but there are some references to
the mythological version that you may
not have noticed in the movies on one
page of the book there is a boy-like
form with a snake coming out of its
mouth
this is likely a reference to how valik
is depicted in the lesser key of solomon
as an angelically winged boy riding on a
two-headed dragon
in the movies valik is a shape-shifter
whose form seems to change based on what
makes its victims most uncomfortable
there's also this image valic is
commonly associated with a snake
serpent symbols can be found throughout
the monastery and there are multiple
occasions where the demon is introduced
as valic the defiler the profane the
marquee of snakes the bird is probably
there to represent malthus an earl of
hell in mythology who you may know is
the demon who's connected to the
annabelle doll i did an entire video on
the history of malthus if you're
interested
that would also leave the question of
who these other two horned demons are
perhaps other villains that we'll meet
in future conjuring movies
on another page you'll see a more
familiar sight the nun form of valic
which seems to be its favorite form to
use but there may be a reason that we
see the nun form so often
on the side you'll notice another
picture of a snake eating its own tail
this is known as an oroborus a mark seen
in many ancient cultures as a symbol for
the cycle of life
death and rebirth we don't exactly know
what vallec's endgame is but we know
that it has a strong desire to possess
as explained in the conjuring too
perhaps by possessing someone and moving
into a new body
valic feels a new sense of life and the
auroboris is a sign of the tendency to
go from body to body creating a cycle of
new demonic possessions the text written
in the book isn't legible but father
burke does read some of it aloud and i
am going to
roll it so roll it
and out of the ground foreign
every beast of the field and every
bird of the sky whatever the man
called the living creature that was
its name
this passage is part of the biblical
text of genesis 2 19. so i looked up the
meaning of that passage and found the
following the act of naming something is
meaningful in the book of genesis this
often implies rule and responsibility
over that thing
this may explain why lorraine is
eventually able to defeat valic but
we'll get there when we get there now
you may be thinking this valid guy
sounds like kind of a bad dude going
around and possessing people and crap i
mean who would actually want to summon
valik
if we go back to the mythological
readings of ars gowezia it describes the
benefits of calling upon this malevolent
force he perfectly locates hidden
treasure and finds where serpents may be
hiding
which he delivers onto the hands of the
conjurer valik is void of any force or
strength but has dominion over 30
legions of devils
if this holds true for the conjuring
version of alec it explains why the duke
of saint karda built this fortress and
tried
so hard to summon valik there he was
driven by the allure of power and riches
the book also associates a sigil or a
symbol considered to have magical power
to each of the 72 demons if you've seen
hereditary you may recognize the
necklace as an example of this they
don't lean too hard on this in the
conjuring but i did notice that the
summoning ground inside the abbey almost
seems to resemble the sigil of valic
but upon closer inspection the outer
ring is formed by a double auroboris
this image can be seen in one of the
other books next to a more traditional
demonic form resembling a gargoyle i've
always
assumed that this is valak's true form
because it's also seen labeled as valik
on another page and it seems to be the
form
used when valic enters and eventually
exits our world
that brings me back to the summoning
ritual which as i mentioned was thwarted
by the church
they took over the castle and converted
it into the abbey the place was fully
surrounded by crosses to keep the evil
contained and nuns prayed there
continuously working in shifts so that
the place was constantly being blessed
earlier i called valik the main boss of
the conjuring franchise and this is why
malthus from the annabelle movies is
considered one of the most powerful
supernatural entities but in order to
keep it contained the warrens have a
priest come twice a month to bless the
rune
to keep valic contained however several
nuns have to work together
24 7 and even this is only enough to
hold the demon off for so long
one of them describes the bombs of war
shaking the abbey and once again
cracking open the gateway
i'm guessing that this was during world
war ii and romania was subject to air
raids during that war romania was hit
with air raids in 1943 and 1944 less
than a decade before the main events of
the nun which takes place in 1952 but
ever since those bombs dropped an
unidentified nun began stalking the
corridors of the abbey at night but this
nun was anything but whole
[Music]
as perhaps the most powerful entity in
the world of the conjuring with the
ability to take on any form
why does valak so often choose to become
a simple nun
why not a creepy clown or mummy or
coraline's mom
the answer lies in its setting it's
something unholy
it takes on different forms to deceive
us and pray on our weaknesses
valic uses the nun form to blend in with
the order and eventually purge or
corrupt each of them
this could be the reason that the nuns
are generally never supposed to leave
the abbey so they cannot be a vessel for
valon's escape
it was likely just after valik was
released but before they realized that
valk was among them and locked the place
down when sister charlotte visited the
abbey while she doesn't personally
encounter valik she does have kind of a
close call since it seems to appear in
the background of her photo
one by one valik picks off each of the
remaining nuns until only two remain
they go into the dungeon area where the
gateway is to try to retrieve a relic
that they believe will save them but
when valik quickly strikes down the
elder of the two the lone survivor must
give herself
up so that the demonic presence does not
have a vessel to escape in
not long after a delivery guy named
maurice most people just call him
frenchie discovers the remains and word
gets around to the vatican that trouble
is afoot in romania they send one of
their best priests father burke and an
inexperienced novitiate or nun in
training named irene palmer to
investigate
valik watches them as they arrive and
somehow the scene of the incident is
still fresh
valid continues to haunt the premises
but the ghosts of the nuns that
inhabited it still linger so when sister
irene and father burke speak to the
reverend mother the highest-ranking nun
in the convent i'm assuming that this is
actually valic
posing as the reverend mother because
the throne she's sitting on has an
oroborus on it
she tells them that the nuns are about
to take a vow of silence for the evening
but they can stay over and speak to them
in the morning this may be part of alex
plan to try to eliminate burke and
possess irene during the night
as frenchie heads back to the town after
escorting them valak uses a variety of
scary forms to send him running so that
he's unlikely to want to come back for
them
including this thing if we're doing
spin-offs on every character that
appears we gotta do this guy
burke is awoken by what appears to be a
boy he performed a failed exorcism on
years ago when he catches up to him a
snake slithers out of the boy's mouth
and comes for burke knocking him back
into an open casket which becomes
instantly buried by valak's magic
next sister irene is lured out of bed
into the chapel where she sees the
demon's shadow circle around her until
it gets to the mirror and appears in a
corporeal form behind her but only in
the reflection before it roars at her
and shatters the mirror
valik appeared to them each in different
forms because it represents that which
they have yet to overcome
for burke he hasn't stopped feeling
guilty about the child he was unable to
save so valik appears as that child to
prey on his weakness for irene
it appears as the nun because she hasn't
made the commitment to take her vows yet
they are each confronted by a challenge
that they have yet to overcome
irene hears a bell ringing in the
graveyard signifying that burke had been
buried alive and was using his lifeline
you should learn from his example and
when you do make sure you hit
all notifications the next morning they
come back to speak with the nuns not
realizing that there are none remaining
like n-o-n-e-nun i assume that valik is
the one to open the gate for them and
probably also the one to close it
that evening locking irene inside for
another night as father burke studies
the map
valik this time posing as the abbess
tells him that he won't find another way
in
it's too late father sister
irene is lost this also plays into
burke's fears because he doesn't want
sister irene to be the latest person he
was unable to say
valek grabs him using the same decrepit
hands that attacked him while he was
trapped in the coffin and they break off
and crumble on the floor
he also encounters a zombified version
of the boy that's been haunting him his
demonic hands protrude from the walls
when he reaches him he has valik's
signature yellow eyes and a forked
tongue a trait commonly associated with
the devil
burke breaks free and runs for it
probably narrowly avoiding being
possessed and when he looks back the
ancient evil has reverted to its
unnerving
nun form meanwhile irene awakes from a
nightmare and discovers a door that's
labeled finite hikideo or
god ends here she too encounters valic
who creates a turbulent windstorm in the
hallway
and you already know what's coming she
gets aerated across the hall but she's
rescued by the ghost of sister awana and
joins the others in a little midnight
emergency prayer sash this is probably a
scene that took place at some point in
the 1940s just after valic had begun
coming after the lives of these nuns and
we're just seeing a slightly altered
version of it that includes sister irene
but since i don't know that 100
i'm keeping it here in the chronology
i'm also not really clear on if the
prayers of the ghost nuns would actually
help hold the seal at all but we can at
least say that them encouraging sister
irene to pray would have some effect
because sister irene is real it doesn't
come without cost though because valik
makes like that goth girl you dated in
college and scratches a pentagram into
her back
burke and frenchie team up against a
re-animated version of sister victoria
based on what we know from ed and
lorraine's various lectures this isn't
possession because the demon would need
a soul in order to possess someone and
that would defeat the purpose of sister
victoria's sacrifice so what's probably
going on here is that valic is just
moving around her body in the same way
that malthus moves around the annabelle
doll
he's moved around to give the impression
of possession anyway they catch up with
sister irene who finally realizes the
nun she's been talking to were only an
apparition
there's no one left we have our answer
father
as if there was any doubt before this
place is no longer holy
valic next encounters them in the
dungeon area beyond the door with the
latin text
translating to god ends here this area
represents hell within the monastery so
it's fitting that this should be where
their final battle with valic takes
place
they split up to search for the gate
because you know that's the best plan in
a horror movie sister irene enters one
of the rooms and valik appears in the
form of a
what's the word for a group of nuns uh
like a horde or
a flock okay i looked it up apparently
it's called a superfluity which was
definitely
not the word i was looking for but
whatever we'll just call it a crowd of
nuns
each of them has their faces covered and
they're able to overcome irene
and possess her you failed
just as you failed everyone in your life
tomorrow i finished
[Music]
irene's apparent possession does not
last long as frenchie kicks down the
door and encounters the possessed irene
who irrigates him into a pillar
we've seen a lot of air eating in this
franchise and really just in this era of
horror in general but that one looks
kind of painful
however sister irene still has the holy
grail hanging around her neck and
frenchie is able to smear some of it
onto irene which immediately exercises
the demon
we've seen characters use incantations
holy water and crosses as part of the
exorcism process but this is by far the
most effective and powerful method
obviously there's going to be a very
limited supply though so from a balance
perspective this doesn't break the game
in favor of the good guys
valik reverts back to the nun form and
grabs hold of frenchie after sending
irene flying out of the room and he
becomes the next
victim of alex possession this is the
only time we see valik possess someone
on screen and it's different from any of
the possessions we've seen in other
conjuring universe movies the other
entities possess a person by basically
puking this black stuff into their mouth
i mean i don't really know how else to
describe it but with valic we see a
snake slither out of its mouth and into
frenchies there's also an image of this
in one of the duke's books
the reason i bring this up is that it
connects back to the idea that i
mentioned earlier that the auroboris is
always associated with valic as a sign
of the cycle of demonic possessions as
the demon goes from person to person
all evidence points to these demons
being able to essentially split
themselves to be able to do multiple
things at once
so while valic was incubating inside of
frenchie's body the nun form could
continue to terrorize irene and burke by
rising out of the water that now covered
the gateway and attempting to drown
irene
burke tried to send the demonic entity
back to hell but was overcome by its
power so it's ultimately irene who
tricks valik by pretending to offer the
holy grail perhaps the biggest bane that
still threatened the creature and
instead spitting its contents out onto
the unholy being causing it to be torn
apart as the gateway to hell appears to
close
the fact that she defeats it by spitting
is significant because there had long
been a superstition in the nearby
village that they should spit on the
ground whenever the cursed abby is
mentioned sister
irene's victory also makes sense phallic
was still attacking her in its nun form
probably not realizing that she had
taken her vows shortly before irene was
no longer afraid of this religious
commitment so the appearance of the nun
would no longer intimidate her but this
wouldn't be the last time that valic
would utilize this appearance the demon
lies dormant inside of frenchie's body
and uses it as a vessel to break free
out of the circle of crosses that
surrounded the abbey the evil was no
longer contained to a singular location
it would continue to incubate within him
as he eventually settled down and got
married at which point the symptoms of
his possession made themselves
noticeable
in 1970 help was called in frenchie is
diagnosed by a pair of paranormal
investigators named edin lorraine warren
lorraine is most likely the sister or at
least a very close relative of sister
irene given that irene is from
bridgeport connecticut the same place
that lorraine was born
they also both have clairvoyant visions
and that ability seems to be hereditary
lorraine's daughter exhibits the trade
as well
when ed and lorraine meet frenchie it's
one of the worst possessions they've
ever seen
he's speaking in fluent latin despite
having a third grade education and
inverted crosses can be seen emanating
from under his skin
the couple assisted on the exorcism and
since lorraine was a medium it took a
huge toll on her so much that she locked
herself away for eight days and never
spoke about the experience for many
years it's possible that valic wanted
revenge on the family after irene burned
it so badly in romania and it wouldn't
be done with them quite yet
we never find out if this exorcism was
successful but we do know that the
results were grim
for frenchie and his family in 1976
lorraine has a vision containing valic
while investigating an unrelated case in
long island and the experience
contributed to making it one of the most
haunting cases of her career
[Music]
this is as close to hell as i ever went
again with frenchie no longer around
valak searched for a new target there
were probably other possessions that
took place between frenchie's demise in
1970 and the happenings in enfield
england in 1977 but so far they have not
been documented in any movie
the best targets for a demon are those
who are weak of faith as we learn from
sister charlotte in annabelle creation
and one thing that can cause a person's
faith to weaken is distress in their
family life
the timing isn't a coincidence negative
entities often feed off emotional
distress
so valak's next target is the hodgson
family who recently lost their father
when he ran away and had twins with the
woman from down the street
they most likely opened themselves up to
the poltergeist when sisters janet and
margaret used a spirit board to ask a
vulnerable question
is dada for coming home as we know
thanks to other controvers entries
reaching out to the spirit world to try
to get information or talk to a loved
one can be dangerous because doing so is
essentially inviting an inhuman spirit
into your life the inhuman spirit may
trick the victim making him or her think
that they're talking to the spirit of a
person when in fact they're talking to a
malevolent entity
so asking if their dad is coming home
told valic that this family is already
struggling on an emotional level and
they would be the perfect targets but
after nearly being defeated by irene
valach wanted to operate in secrecy this
time so instead of haunting the family
directly it took hold of the ghost of a
man named bill wilkins making it seem
like bill was the one terrorizing the
family during the middle of the night
janet is transported downstairs in front
of the chair that bill wilkins passed on
as taught by ed warren the og horror
history teacher before emo abraham
lincoln took over there are three stages
of demonic activity
infestation oppression and possession
the hodgins began to experience the
symptoms of infestation
janet was terrorized in her dreams and
valik forced her to sleep walk
sleep talk and sleep hawk wait no not
sleep you can go back to sleep sleephawk
but valik would do other stuff like
manifest the image of bill wilkins to
scare them move around toys and objects
to give the impression that these items
are possessed intimidate them with
voices in the knights
and mess with the tv or as they called
it the telly
this is also another example of alec
using reflections to scare a victim just
like it did to sister irene in the
chapel
at this point the activity escalates to
stage two oppression this involves
shaking beds
slamming doors bite marks flying
furniture and other very clear-cut
paranormal mayhem
the family flees the house in the middle
of the night and brings in outside help
police officers reporters videographers
passersby and others all experience
the phenomenon it is around this time
that a strange occurrence goes down back
in the u.s
that could suggest that we may see valic
again in a future
conjuring installment
[Music]
while valik was making the hodgson
family more miserable in the united
kingdom lorraine was growing more
paranoid over in the united states ed
had seen valik in a dream which caused
him to create a painting of the creepy
nun and lorraine would have a vision of
her own there's also a scene where judy
is frozen by the disturbing image of
valak though it's not entirely clear if
this was all part of loren's vision or
if they both were able to see valic i
have the sense that judy does see valik
though because the name appears multiple
times in her artwork lorraine would also
discover the demon's name
in her own vision i
want my mtv as the enfield's poltergeist
gets more and more attention in the
media
valic would hide behind the ghost of the
old man bill wilkins
from my understanding of the events it
essentially used bill as a shield
commandering his voice and in some cases
his appearance and this also made it so
that valk's demonic energy would not be
picked up on by a medium
listen to the way that janet would
eventually describe the phenomenon
does it feel like it's coming from
inside you no
you're like it's coming from behind me
like i'm being used
but bill was not the only facade that
the inhuman spirit would use to its
advantage the hodgson's youngest son
billy has a zoetrope toy that tells the
nursery rhyme of the crooked man
billy used to sing along with it in
order to work on improving his speech
impediment but he never quite overcame
it
valic tends to use the form of whatever
its subject has not overcome
so when billy is alone valik appears to
him as the crooked man what's not
entirely explained is if the crooked man
once existed as a separate entity like
bill wilkins or if it was just valik
taking the form that it saw on the toy
i'm guessing the crooked man is a
separate entity though based on this
line from ed the old man the crooked man
they're just facades trying to keep us
from seeing the real evil in that house
i don't think valk would risk exposing
itself when it had kept its involvement
a secret for so long the demon would not
want the church finding out and sending
people in to destroy it
you'll notice that it never uses the nun
form until lorraine shows up the
in-universe explanation is that valik
used the nun to attack lorraine's faith
which was shaken by this encounter that
scared her so much
all of those years ago director james
wan explained the decision further in an
instagram post during editing i deemed
this beautifully designed and sculpted
horned demon
too out of left field for the film it
needed to be more grounded and personal
something that would take lorraine's
faith and try to test slash corrupt it i
remember the real life lorraine warren
talking about her love and reverence for
her nun friends and a lightbulb went off
thus the demon nun was born so we went
back and replaced all of the horned
demon scenes with the nun during
additional photography
many of the hodgson's neighbors donated
crosses that were hung up all around
janet and margaret's room in hopes that
this could weaken the evil and prevent
objects from moving around but unlike
the circle of crosses at the abbey and
romania this is not enough to contain
valic the case would eventually gain
enough notoriety that the church decides
to send ed and lorraine across the sea
to see what's up when they arrive
valik remembers them and hopes to get
bill to scare them away it said it wants
to hurt you
when did it say that right now on
december 21
1977 they perform a test to see if the
spirit haunting the house was speaking
through janet or if she was just making
the noises on her own
they're unable to determine that it was
all janet but lorraine is still
skeptical because she doesn't sense any
presence in the house
that night janet is transported in her
sleep to the first floor ceiling where
she sees old man bill sitting up on his
chair
he gets up and goes upstairs then she's
pulled upwards into her room the room
where most of the paranormal instances
had taken place
valak's presence causes all of the
crosses in the room to invert and janet
encounters old man bill who has the
yellow glowing eyes of the demon ed and
lorraine get into the room in time to
rescue janet from being suffocated at
the foot of a window curtain a day later
on the 22nd ed helps fix a floor in the
basement of the house where valic rises
again
it first looks as if it's going to
attack ed and i surmise this is in order
to lure mrs hodgson into the flooded
area where it can then attack and bite
her in the arm
this attack strategy isn't random
phallic wants to freak out the family
and
isolate them by making it look like
they're just making the whole thing up
when ed finds the retainer with the
teeth or as they call them in the uk
teef that line up with the bite mark on
peggy's arm he's going to question if it
was placed there by a supernatural
entity or if it was planted there by
peggy herself to sell the story
that is the reason that valic has
everyone turn away while janet is making
the demonic voices and the reason that
the only convincing proof of a demonic
infestation happens while nobody from
outside the household is present
this leads into the next part of alex
plan the house is readyed up with video
recording equipment hoping to catch some
of the supernatural happenings on tape
but valik plays it smart it knows that
it's managed to trick lorraine up to
this point by hiding behind the ghost of
bill wilkins undetected but if proof of
the poltergeist is captured ed in the
rain will take it back to the church and
they'll send in a bunch of their people
just as they did at the abbey of saint
carter so instead the demon devises a
plan to put a stop to the investigation
it tells janet she has to create a fake
paranormal incident in front of the
cameras threatening to kill her family
if she doesn't comply
so she does just that sticking knives
into the table throwing and destroying
furniture and smashing all the dishes in
the kitchen
the audio guy picks up a strange sound
which they trace to janet who is mangled
in an electrical closet where she speaks
bill's voice
saying more nonsensical phrases the
whole incident was recorded by a
paranormal skeptic the psychologist
named anita gregory who is happy to have
found proof that the hodgsons were
faking the haunting once the tape gets
out the public gains the impression that
everything was a hoax and all the
investigators and reporters clear out
once again giving the family and more
importantly valik their privacy back
luckily for the hajj sins ed figures out
that bill wilkins was trying to covertly
send a message by overlapping the two
audio recordings
upon hearing this lorraine has another
vision where she speaks to the real bill
wilkins and gains an understanding of
the true nature of valik's presence for
the first time
[Music]
lorraine has another vision or perhaps
this one is more of an astral projection
of her in the green street house where
she speaks to the real bill wilkins
uncorrupted by the evil manipulation of
valic for the first time he tells her
that he came here to see his family but
he can't go
because it wants her so badly breaking
this down bill is saying that he entered
the world of spirits instead of moving
on to heaven because he thought he would
be able to see his deceased family
members but he discovered they were not
there and he wanted to go on but valic
would not let go of him because valik
wanted to use him as a piece of its plan
to possess
janet's soul when lorraine asks how to
stop it bill leaves her with a riddle i
am given and i am taken
i was there at your first breath but you
didn't ask for me but i will follow you
to your death
before she can figure it out valik
appears and essentially breaks up the
mental connection
and this is the first time that lorraine
has been able to sense the inhuman
spirit that her family member had gone
up against decades before
the answer to bill's riddle is a name a
name is given at birth
a name is taken by people throughout
your life to identify you you don't ask
for a name but
it follows you to your debt the one part
of the riddle that would have been
misleading for me is the line i was
there at your first breath
because that's not always the case i
think a lot of couples name their baby
after it is born
maybe bill should have said i was there
at your first birthday party or
something
so lorraine's realization that she needs
a name to have dominion over valik
goes back to the genesis passage that i
mentioned earlier it is man's ability to
name something that gives man
power over that thing anyway as ed and
lorraine rushed back to the house vallec
is now on a full-on reign of terror
stage two of demonic activity is
oppression and judging how this stage is
getting worse and worse for the family i
can only assume that valic is getting
very close to stage 3
possession it seems like it was even
already starting to possess janet for
short periods of time if that's a
possibility when the warrens arrive
peggy is locked out of the house in a
full state of panic ed tries to break in
through the front window and the demon
holds the couch across the room
to block his entry so he goes around to
the back to go through the laundry room
and break in from under the floorboards
but once inside valak locks the door
effectively separating him from lorraine
the entity messes with the pipes and
scalds ed's face with piping hot water
partially blinding him but he's able to
hobble his way to the upstairs bedroom
where janet is about to walk out of an
open window and impale herself on the
spiky tree stump that waits below
i'm not entirely sure why valic would do
this since we've kind of established
that when someone dies a demon can no
longer possess them and it's pretty
clear that valak's main goal is to
possess her but as i have in other
videos i'll attempt to justify why valic
might have behaved like this
in annabelle we saw in the book the
devil's welcome that valk and malthus
are just two of the many demons detailed
that all
answer to belial who is basically the
leader of all demons we can even see
valid symbol the oro boris appear way
back in that movie we've also seen in
both annabelle and the nun that
summoning these demons from hell
usually involves making a human
sacrifice along with some kind of spell
maybe this was all part of valak's plan
to summon another demonic presence
possibly belial ed catches her before
this can happen but this leaves him at
risk to fall out of the window himself
lorraine comes in and finds valek
standing in the corner as ed
tries to reel in janet she runs to save
ed but valak's scream easily sends her
flying backwards into the wall however
she uses the demon's name to gain
dominion over it
upon saying this valik appears to
crumble and when the rain condemns it
back to hell it breaks down even further
revealing its true form to her for the
first and only time
before shrinking down into a void and
disappearing this would be the last
confirmed interaction that the warrens
have with valik however this may not
mean the character is gone for good
as i mentioned valik takes on more than
one persona during the 1977 enfield
poltergeist saga so one of these facades
was the manifestation of a nursery rhyme
called the crooked man after many of the
warren's cases they bring home a trinket
and put it in their room of cursed
objects ed describes these objects as
being bearers of evil spirits
almost like keeping a genie in a bottle
for the enfield case they bring home
johnny's crooked man zoatrope if valik
went back to hell i'm guessing the
crooked man is the one trapped inside
this toy
that seems to leave things open for
another evil doer to stumble upon the
evocation books left behind by the duke
of saint carter and summon valik to once
again
cross the threshold and terrorize our
world regardless of what the future
holds i'll be sure to cover it here
if you want to explore the complete
histories of other entities found in the
conjuring universe go ahead and check
out that playlist on the left and
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week ring the death
bell for all notifications and i'll see
you in the next one
assuming we both survive